hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to bad dream coma now
we're gonna go into the hospital which
was one of the middle portions of the
last one or was it one of the first ones
I have no idea now I feel like as we go
on these chapters are gonna get longer
and longer or maybe they're gonna be
exactly the same but I imagine that the
puzzles are gonna get even more and more
interesting now what's fascinating about
this is the first time we went through
bad dream the series like it was
intricate and it was interesting but
this is in a whole different way like
it's vastly improved from the last time
that we went through here
and I don't know why I decided to rifle
through all the trash at first just
wanted to clean up around here
oh hi a new person hey you got so awful
you got some punchable Birds over there
in one piece yeah that's me should I ask
about what the knocking is that's
impressive oh good thank you
you seem lost I you know me and being
lost and what let me explain you the
situation we're trapped in this dream
for some reason what we can't wake up
and nobody knows why everything here is
an illusion the monsters blood wounds
are not real the only thing real things
are pain and fear people are frightened
with the vision of endless suffering and
disability the terrified minds are
continually creating new beasts why is
it getting darker in here we have to
find a way to wake up as soon as
possible
afterwards it may be too late it'd be
best oh damn I gotta go see you later
okay bye puppet man how you doing bird
I'm not gonna punch you I swear why do
you have an ear though
the punch yeah I wasn't gonna punch you
Oh 9-1-1 no I don't work but that's
there out of order lie get out of your
fly
I don't mind smashing you okay I fly get
out of here fly the most my new little
details there
oh hi sir how you doing your pain real
what's with this flask on the ground
patient card several fatal wounds
paralyzed traumatized impossible to cure
and rehabilitate only solution find a
way to wake up find a way to to wake up
all right sir
wake up it's a dream you're not actually
hurt you loser oh this guy had a lot of
days here can ID card nothing nothing
was this this life is fake yeah I know
this guy's injuries are fake I mean I
guess the pain is real oh yeah ah hi
what's wrong with that teddy bear oh god
no okay are you doing alrighty then you
have a very faint heartbeat there's got
to be stuff in these gold
I think there's drinking too much water
for my own good good you know I'll leave
it like this hi okay why did you do that
why did who did that and why what
rapscallion kid threw a rock at that
window so why is this here there must be
a reason right
all the bugs are coming out alright
who's there Oh No oh it is work strange
earthquake what causes him I don't know
that other guy seemed to know what the
[ __ ] did I just see no wait
did I see something or was I crazy was I
crazy or did I see something as I was
walking out that room I feel like I'm
crazy but I don't know what when did
that get different oh it's - oh I see hi
ok alright ok alright I didn't know this
area was here but it seems familiar from
the last time I was at this game
hello trash games Internet if this
computer is infected great what does
that mean it's 18 5 I don't know what
that means
alrighty then why is this window in this
computer all kinds of cracked oh here we
go I don't know what I just did what did
I just do alright hi lady
spiders hatched in my kitchen is that a
euphemism and also it sounds like a
personal problem anyway so I yourself
yes by your problem can you deal with
them why do I need to deal with them I'm
here looking at the moon trying to
ignore weird doors going off all over
the place I don't know what I just what
did I just hit oh you gave me a key
please ok lady I don't
that's not your kitchen
that source got some real umph to it
alrighty then disclaimer every action
has a reaction our minds are capable of
creating monsters we can't leave this
dream so we don't want it to become a
nightmare
don't do anything bad or stupid for the
sake of us all God what would happen if
I what would happen if I just started
murdering all the birds God that would
be an interesting way to go about this I
made SOS okay I don't know how to help
you maybe some more detail than SOS
that's not the kitchen
you must be yeah okay it's over there hi
hi dad leo neighbor I don't want to
punch that spider I had the very strong
urge to punch these spiders but I don't
want to do that because they're my
friends I am oh I got blood on my hands
I could have nope I couldn't have put
them in the goddamn jar spiders ate me
now that's not my oh god that goes
downhill so fast that goes downhill so
fast load autosave please Oh God from
the beginning oh jeez ah see there we go
now I can jar them get in the jar get in
the jar I'll get in the jar there we go
all the spiders have been taken care of
now that lady will be happy what's that
you've caught the spiders in the jar
well they're pretty cute I know right
and they hate you if you kill
can I get them always wanted a pet
someone you treat them nice treat them
nice lady thank you for your help you're
welcome now I can go back to work
oh that's good boy me baby don't let me
see her in the kitchen
hi do you need something this is key for
I don't know but I guess I'll find out
later washroom oh the bathroom key ah
this bathroom is less than fun oh my
mouse has a rough auction who's in that
tour I want to touch that I don't want
to get blood on my hands
[Music]
lu-shi okay I poke you oh that's
probably not the good idea
I'm not gonna poke the randomized that I
see in two bathrooms oh god I can't do
that like this whole game is just really
cool like the details I love the details
the details are so cool they're gonna do
that you want some hair in there alright
fine then smoocher well I got a key I
don't understand how a key a key came
out of the toilet not like a flirt do
you need something
no I don't you keep up with your
amazingly amazing plays here what about
the key to here now what about the key
to the yeah that's it hello Doctor Oh
um question are you okay
I have that syringe no apparently not
this is assistant says z ZZ Top okay
call me 555 279 okay five five five 279
can do I can call that no I can't but I
can take the number of it I can take the
number off of here yeah
five five five five five five two seven
nine hey why do I have eyes
I don't want eyes would you like a shiny
bottle cap oh love me birds like me
don't think like love is no love will
come in time I think oh but you like a
shiny bottle cap oh you such a good verb
oh no I just realized what I'm doing I'm
building a bear head no you can have
eyes Hey Oh
uh you wanna ears you want hair oh hi
hello welcome I thought I was building a
bear head but things got different
puppet man let me help you
oh all right then
much better thanks thank you for help
tell me what exactly happened at the
graveyard have you found any clues is
that the guy from the original game am I
not the original guy I was attacked a
few steps from the game I haven't found
anything useful I didn't get the chance
to look around I'm sorry to disappoint
you it's fine I appreciate that you at
least tried few people have here have
the courage to do that it seems that
some tips regarding our immortality are
at the graveyard can you check it out
for me I have to look for the nurse
we're not looking for anything concrete
just look around for some information
okay the fastest way to get to the
graveyard is by bus bus stop is right
next to the hospital good luck okay
alright go to the graveyard by bus okay
alrighty then
I guess that's all there is then how do
how do I get out of here again what what
what oh okay well I couldn't left at any
time
oh the lying oh hi balloon
I shouldn't shouldn't do nothing about
that I don't want to be mean and have
anybody crying on my behalf so where's
the goddamn bus dude would that look bad
so what's that although I got it out a
dead Apple that's nice okay don't cross
don't go in there I don't think I want
to anyway okay where am I alrighty then
ah cuz a piece of paper yeah it's good
it's hard to remember exactly what I've
been through already but here's the bus
stop anyway so that's good
Oh fishbone I got a fishbone great oh
wait wait and wait how do I inspect that
oh no way that's this is a bus ticket
that's the bus stop sign so I need to
find the other pieces of this boss
ticket to be able to get through here
why would I do that
they're good reads haha I did that and
you feel bad oh okay maybe I could cut
my way across the line there's gotta be
something here right wait oh I threw
that away I cleaned up after myself hope
you all are very proud of me that was
something that took a lot of guts I know
I'm a pretty awesome dude but what
exactly wait-wait-wait-wait just add
brainwave whoa never mind
had the wrong brainwave thought I was
onto something realized I didn't even
need to be on that thing that I was on
okay there's one more piece of the
puzzle somewhere around here oh where
was that
well like okay I guess I'm good now got
me a bus ticket can I
oh hi mr. bus okay I did it yeah the
birds love me I think I'm such a nice
guy and the birds love me so yeah anyway
that is chapter two that did take me a
bit longer to solve so huh they make it
harder and harder as time goes on but
I'm starting to get I'm trying to pieces
together I'm not starting to get it it's
still throwing me for a loop I love it
though
I love the intricacy of it it's so
interesting it's so goddamn interesting
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought of
it down in the comments below and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]